all right goomy so as as long as i can
remember on the internet
you know there's always been you create
passwords and i feel like every year
they're asking me to create
more and more heart or more difficult to
remember passwords
why is this happening and why is the
just the password creation process so
important
yeah so basically your password is
really that key to the front door of
your house and we have to make sure that
your password is unique and it's also
very strong
as you can imagine if you use the same
key across all of the houses in the
universe then any everybody would have
that key and they can get into your
house as well and so it is really
important to make sure that not only
that you have a strong password but for
all of those accounts that you do care
about each of them are different from
each other right and there are certain
accounts that i mean it is a good model
i do this okay if someone were to get
access to this account is how bad is it
my banking account my social media
that's those are pretty important so i
want to make sure i have super strong
passwords there uh well if it's if it's
something that's a little bit more
frivolous or something and it's not the
end of the world someone has access
right now you always see these rules you
know at least this many characters
a number of a letter uppercase lowercase
why do we keep getting all these
constraints being put on us on our
passwords
well the whole point of it is to make
the password as hard to guess as
possible so um you don't want to you
know use common words or things that can
get easily guessed and it's actually
very common for users to use their names
or their pet names or birthdays these
are things that attackers can also guess
and we'll try to get into your accounts
as well
that being said um
the the way that we keep safe online i
think the advice um has changed over the
years and so um
it actually you don't actually have to
change your password that often as long
as you know that there hasn't been a
compromise and that you do have a strong
password and it's also okay
to like write your password even on a
post-it if you like but sometimes just
being practical is the best way to
encourage people to actually have these
stronger passwords that they actually
can remember and keep up with
that's super helpful